we've seen countless Qing villains some
are utterly horrifying and others are
completely laughable but there's a
handful that are so terrifying they'll
inspire nightmares these are the Stephen
King movie villains who've kept us up at
night ranked from worst to the very best
the Shawshank Redemption demonstrates
how some of the scariest movie monsters
are the ones you could meet in real life
warden Samuel Norton is a man who's
willing to do whatever it takes to gain
power over others don't you ever mention
money to me again he claims to be a man
of God but he runs Shawshank State
Prison like a slave owner manipulating
inmates to do his bidding and punishing
anyone who doesn't comply ultimately
Norton is a coward he chooses to take
the easy way out when confronted with
his own misdeeds but cowards like Norton
are capable of doing some truly
frightening and despicable things and
they shouldn't be underestimated we
can't say for certain whether Stephen
King has something against organized
religion but religious figures are often
the villains in his story
take Reverend Lowe for example a man of
the cloth with a beastly secret 1985
silver bullet tells the story of a small
town terrorized by a werewolf and the
people who are brave enough to fight the
ungodly creature the film is indicative
of a lot of horror films that came out
in the 1980s it's more cheesy than
actually scary honestly the fact that
Gary Busey is one of the stars tells you
everything you need to know
still werewolves are scary beasts and
the fact that this werewolf is the
town's religious leader makes him all
the more frightening there's nothing
scarier than an evil child and the town
and children of the corn is full of them
some might argue that the scariest
presence in the film is he who walks
behind the rows that's the fertility
demon who dwells in the cornfield and
these nasty kids keep sacrificing the
town's adults in order to appease him of
course demons are bad news on the best
of days but there's something about a
charismatic cult leader a child in this
case it strikes us as even more
horrifying in the dream the Lord did
come to me and he was a shape it was he
who walks behind the road actor John
Franklin does an incredible job
portraying a corrupt power-mad
adolescent thanks to his per for
the film becomes less about the horror
of a cornfield demon more about the
dangers of charismatic leaders with
frightening ulterior motives meat beef
what's worse than buying a new car only
to find out it's pure evil
uh nothing actually christine is a
unique horror film that takes something
as mundane as a car and turns it into an
unstoppable killing machine Christine
isn't one of the most popular King
adaptations but it's still a pretty
intense thrill ride and the film is
certainly worth giving a whirl okay show
me while it's obviously impossible for
an inanimate object to convey emotion
director John Carpenter and his star
Keith Gordon are great at making it seem
like Christine has a personality all her
own
however terrifying that personality may
be fun fact the film's famous
resurrection scene almost didn't happen
on screen Carpenter added it after
production wrapped because he felt the
movie needed more special effects
Stephen King is an absolute master when
it comes to turning life's everyday
comforts into total nightmares Cujo
tells the story of Donna and Tad a
mother and son who are forced into a hot
broken-down car by a rabid Saint Bernard
that's quite literally foaming at the
mouth the film turns out to be less
about a killer dog in more about human
relationships and childhood trauma and
Cujo comes to represent all the terrible
things that are happening in Donna's
family also what's more frightening than
watching a lovable creature turn into a
bloodthirsty monster and through no
fault of his own at the beginning of the
film Cujo is a sweet curious dog who
simply winds up in the wrong place at
the wrong time oh and speaking of being
in the wrong place at the wrong time
throughout the film the audience feels a
real sense of helplessness as they watch
the creature transform before their eyes
in that sense of helplessness soon turns
to utter horror mothers can be monstrous
real-life and in the movies and as far
as bad momma's go you'd be hard-pressed
to find a mother as depraved and
dangerous as Kerris Margaret white she's
a religious zealot who feels an
overwhelming compulsion to punish her
daughter Kari at every turn calling her
a sinner whenever she gets the chance
she's also fond of locking poor Kari in
a prayer closet essentially a broom
closet adorned with candles and
religious icons including the creepiest
crucifix you've ever seen when Kari gets
her first period Margaret tells her it's
because she's had impure thoughts see
the sin of her days and when at the end
of the day she's an all-around miserable
person who thinks sex and sexuality is
sinful and revolting of course margaret
gets hers in the end because having a
telekinetic daughter who throws knives
with her mind isn't without its risks
but while she's alive man
margaret is a frigging nightmare Kurt
Barlow from Salem's Lot is the
quintessential boogeyman the vampire is
barely seen throughout the two-part
miniseries which had a theatrical
release in Europe preferring to prey on
the people of Salem's Lot under a veil
of darkness and chic mystique but when
it finally does show his face he's a
decidedly unsexy vampire there's no
mistaking him for Edward :
[Music]
I'm going to kill you Barlow is more
akin to Nosferatu's central creep
another repulsive monster who doesn't
waste time trying to charm his victims
Barlow keeps his eye on the prize and
just focuses on what he does best
terrorizing the townspeople
[Applause]
[Music]
when he was alive pet cemeteries gage
Creed was a real cute little kid but
after a fatal accident involving an
18-wheeler his father made the perfect
worst choice and decided to go ahead and
reanimate him the result of all this
inadvisable hocus-pocus is not so cute
branches sent to mommy okay maybe he's
still pretty cute nevertheless he turns
into a murderous zombie with a fondness
for scalpels he sneaks he creeps you'll
always find him in the most unexpected
places basically he's a full-fledged
Menace who must be stopped
in the end gages odd mixture of
childlike innocence and unstoppable evil
adds up to pure unadulterated nightmare
fuel as a wise man once said gage is the
embodiment of corrupted innocence a
victim of unfortunate circumstances his
transformation into a tiny monster is
ultimately the byproduct of his father's
grief in that regard Pet Sematary is a
terribly sad film on top of being
absolutely terrifying let's face it most
insects and arachnids are pretty
off-putting in real life the mere sight
of a creepy crawly is a surefire way to
get the blood pumping a fact that horror
directors are all too happy to exploit
well the creatures in the mist are all
super-sized and so is your mounting
sense of dread just take a look at this
angry militia of creepos if you don't
believe us most of the action in the
mist takes place in a single location a
store that suddenly become enveloped in
a thick mysterious fog most of the
people trapped inside are loathe to
venture out those who do explore the
mist end up meeting horrible fates the
mist monsters are otherworldly creatures
that go sight unseen throughout much of
the film but when we finally do catch a
glimpse it's not a happy sight
[Applause]
those oversized tentacles are not for
the faint of heart
and the sharp pincers should give you a
pause to their ghastly malevolent
monsters and it's really best to avoid
them there's certainly no reasoning with
them just try talking some sense into
this guy
these monsters are seemingly unstoppable
- the only way to save yourself from a
gruesome death is to fight back and
that's way easier said than done looking
for a life of fame and glory well Annie
Wilkes will make you think twice about
that misery tells the story of Paul
Sheldon a famous writer who's taken in
by a seemingly gregarious nurse
following a serious car accident Annie
is all too willing to help Paul get back
on his feet but she's also happy to
break his ankles after all she's his
number one fan and she feels things very
strongly I'm also a nurse and in case
you hadn't caught on yet she's also a
total frigging psychopath say what you
made me do
Wilkes holds the poor writer hostage
forcing him to rewrite his latest book
in a way that she deems satisfying and
appropriate no profanity
no cheap endings and when he tries to
escape this horrible predicament
she cobbles him with a sledgehammer all
the while assuring him that she's his
biggest fan Annie is easily one of
Stephen King's most frightening villains
and part of what makes her so terrifying
is Kathy Bates incredible performance
she rightfully earned an Oscar for her
work and it's easy to see why Total Film
said Annie Wilkes is one of cinema's
greatest friendliest monsters indeed
part of what makes Annie so awful is the
fact that she really does love Paul but
when admiration turns into obsession
there's no telling what a person is
capable of doing and Annie is apparently
willing to do anything no matter how
wretched it is the 1980 film adaptation
of The Shining is a bonafide horror
masterpiece director Stanley Kubrick
created a ghostly and ghastly world
inside the Overlook Hotel and his
utterly terrifying film is widely
considered an essential iconic piece of
horror cinema
story revolves around a writer and
family man who loses his mind inside a
haunted hotel which sounds somewhat
straightforward at first but there's a
lot going on here though Kubrick's
vision is something of a departure from
Stephen King's original novel his take
on the haunted hotel has unspeakable
horrors waiting behind every door and
just around every corner as the story
goes the Overlook Hotel was apparently
built on an Indian burial ground and any
horror fan knows that's never a good
sign
throughout the film the formidable
building establishes itself as something
of a villain in its own right it really
feels like a living breathing entity
with blood on its mind the ghosts that
seem to inhabit the property are all
deranged and diabolical in one way or
another there are elevators full of
blood ballrooms teeming with ghostly
spectres and who the hell knows what's
going on in room 237
from the Grady twins to these two fine
fellows there's something to fear on
every floor of the Overlook Hotel you
can run but you can't hide though the
spectral hotel guests at the Overlook
Hotel are admittedly creepy it's
questionable whether any of them can
physically harm you still there's no
doubt they'll drive you towards madness
using every trick at their disposal
case in point Jack Torrance who totally
loses his mind throughout the course of
the film he starts out as a deeply
frustrated husband and father who seems
to have a rather short fuse but he
slowly transforms into a genuine monster
a monster who happens to be highly
proficient with an axe
taking the job at the Overlook proves to
be Jack's undoing we watch helplessly as
he loses his grip on reality and
sometimes it feels like we're losing it
right along with him he becomes more and
more terrifying with every scene and
when he finally meets his demise there's
something truly awful in that frozen
grimace and the vision stays with us
long after the final frame of the film
of course that final frame is creepy in
its own right if you were a child in the
90s there's a good chance you caught the
it miniseries starring Tim Curry as the
child eating penny wise the dancing
clown Curry's penny wise was a villain
that made kids afraid to turn off their
bedroom lights
not just because clowns are inherently
awful but because this clown can
manifest as your greatest fear he can
also get to you quite easily wherever
you happen to be
although the it miniseries has arguably
lost a bit of its bite in recent years
penny wise the dancing clown is still a
force to be reckoned with in the recent
it films bill skarsgård takes on the
meaty role and his interpretation is
dazzlingly demented in its own right
the pancake makeup the teeth that
hideous dance
the new Pennywise is the perfect villain
for these troubling times at the end of
the day we all get the monsters we
deserve check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite horror movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]